the Texas shooting suspect had a history
of domestic violence
Air Force records showed Devon Kelly was
court-martialed in 2012 for assaulting
his then wife and young stepson he
fractured the child's skull a new report
based on FBI data shows 54% of mass
shootings relate to domestic or family
violence in 42% of the cases the gunman
showed warning signs they include
threats of violence to others
Mary Ellen O'Toole is a former FBI
profiler she is now director of the
forensic science program at George Mason
University and joins us from Washington
good morning good morning help us
understand what you have come to know
about the relationship between domestic
violence and these kinds of incidents
well domestic violence is present in
some of these cases where we can
document it in others it could be
present we just didn't find it but I
think what's really important is that
domestic violence is not a predictor for
mass homicide there are many people who
do engage in domestic violence they
never go on to become mass killers but
because it's prominent in a number of
cases that we've seen over time it it
really does need to be considered as
perhaps one of the warning behaviors
that we already know about okay but
what's the difference between those that
do and those that don't I mean what can
we find any link that turns those that
have committed domestic violence to go
further none that I know of none that I
know of it there are other things that
can really provoke someone to make the
decision to go forward and that does
appear at least in my experience to be
more personality based than it does
based on domestic violence
well one Texas official said yesterday
if the shooter was just angry at his
mother-in-law and wanted to do something
to his mother-in-law why would he bring
an assault rifle to a church venue that
only had very limited access to get in
and out what does that tell you about
what he was thinking well that tells me
that he wasn't he was not just motivated
by attacking his mother-in-law who was
who was not there it tells me that he
was really mission oriented and that his
intent was for maximum lethality and
when someone is intent on maximum
lethality
because they want to kill as many people
as they can
engaging in that behavior makes them
feel powerful it makes them feel
omnipotent it it underscores their
predatory behavior so their intent was
far beyond just killing a single person
so what can be done to prevent a person
who has this kind of history what can be
this is so troubling Mary Ellen that we
keep seeing this over and over and over
again you keep hearing conflicting
things about the people that carry this
out are there any warning signs or
anything that we can do to prepare
ourselves or be on guard for something
well there are there are warning signs
that occur before and some of those
incur things like include things like
leakage and that means that someone
tells a person either directly or
indirectly what they're going to do
their behavior changes they become
obsessed with other mass killers they
began to change their pattern of
behaviors so they're either amassing
more firearms or they're going out and
practicing so it's a collective set of
behaviors that they display beforehand
and unfortunately law enforcement may
not be in their living room watching
that behavior as it evolves it becomes
imperative that someone within the
family who observes it comes forward to
law enforcement because it's observable
behavior but oftentimes what happens is
that family members or friends will
begin to normalize it or try to handle
it themselves and it becomes
uncontrollable behavior Mary Ellen
O'Toole thank you very much for joining
us this morning